[Music]
the two business models of states
in the future will be i think rather
than course it will be subscription
inflation subscription we just described
inflation the idea is this bitcoin is
short-term volatile but shows immense
long-term appreciation
the us dollar is actually the opposite
it is short-term relatively stable you
know forget about inflation for now i'll
come back to that it is short term
relatively stable but over the long term
you can see it has had a huge drop in
purchasing power
now right now this is talked about in a
moral way and i understand why because
essentially the quote fiat engineers
don't really acknowledge this as a
trade-off or even recognizes as such it
gets back to this thing of like the
religious taboo but if you think about
it from an engineering mindset most
people hold a portfolio they don't hold
100 btc and 100 or 100 well some people
100 usd but you don't usually hold 100
btc you hold some btc and some usd why
because some of this is like stable on a
daily basis
and and the rest is appreciating over
time right okay now here's the concept
what if
those are just opposite engineering
trade-offs that is to say
the long-term depreciation of fiat
provides effectively the funds
to stabilize in the short term
okay and just to think about that from
an equation standpoint if you were to do
like an order book is
uh probably not what i have in my
imagination so why don't you tell me
okay so this was something actually
which i didn't know before i got into
cryptocurrency and i think i mean the
number of people who know what this is
is probably increased by a hundred or a
thousand x over the last 10 years and
it's very important because
it describes what like how how supply
and demand and prices
really interact like prices prices don't
come from storks they they come from
this and where does it come from okay so
let me explain then i'll come all the
way back up so
you go to the store and you buy uh like
i don't know a gallon of milk all right
that's gonna cost you i don't know how
much it is today let's say it's
five bucks okay maybe ten bucks with all
the inflation but all right five bucks
so
fine you're a price taker
okay
if instead you go to the store and you
say i want all your milk
i want uh 200 individual one gallon
bottles i'll pay five bucks per you can
do that but now
if you want yet more milk you need to go
to the next door and they're selling
they have an inventory of 30 gallon
bottles but it's 550.
okay and as you start buying out
inventory here uh word gets around and
people start hiking the price because
they know you're going to walk in and
clear them out of all of this
liquidity of milk okay
and
that is the difference between you know
having like a small enough demand that
you don't really affect the price and
having a large enough demand that you
actually move the market
and one way of thinking about it is
these are like bids that are placed on
either side okay
one store has placed a sell order of 200
gallons of milk at five bucks and the
next door has placed a sell order of 30
gallons of milk at 550 okay and all of
these add up to be all of what is for
sale and you know there might be like a
ton there might be thousands of gallons
if somebody really wants to pay like 20
bucks a gallon there's like thousands of
gallons that become profitable to
produce at that um at that level right
at that price okay
and uh and then conversely demand is
sort of lowest at five dollars but
there'd be a ton of demand there might
be lots of people who would buy a gallon
of milk for a dollar
okay so you can visualize this sort of
v-shaped thing
where the current market clearing price
is five bucks but if a lot of people
suddenly buy and clear out the supply
then the next available unit might be at
like eight bucks or ten bucks and
conversely if there's a huge amount of
supply and there isn't demand the market
clearing price drops from like five
dollars like four or three dollars okay
with me so far i am
so that is called an order book and that
is actually how prices are born prices
literally come from the interaction of
supply and demand so all kinds of people
are being trained as true capitalists
because they're actually seeing the root
acts of the system how prices are set
between supply and demand supply and
demand are now like computable visible
tangible this has huge implications for
lots of things
because those order books are going to
come to everything
as we cryptify the whole world it's not
just btc usd that has an order book
where you're buying units of btc for
blocks of usd or vice versa it's not
just like either usd it's not just every
coin versus every coin it's every asset
versus every asset
okay this is what i call the d5 matrix
essentially every financial
interaction that we think of
so
a digital wallet doesn't just hold
bitcoin it can eventually hold
everything can old fiat currencies
ethereum tokens nfts whatever
and so it's got billions of rows
but it doesn't just hold everything
everything trades against everything but
just to interject for a second i mean a
very concrete i i feel like nfts and
expensive or not expensive uh jpegs are
sort of the
will be an on-ramp it's like a gateway
drug for a lot of people into crypto and
web 3 and so on and you can see
just for people who want to look for
articles on this and certainly you can
see it yourself
but if you compare traditional art to
say open c and collectibles or nfd
artwork on openc
price discovery and
the the sort of transparency of order
book that you're talking about is
is right there and then there are
analytics being built on top of
these marketplaces
just i want to give one example of
what's already happening for folks
exactly right so essentially order books
mean price discovery all kinds of things
suddenly become liquid and priceable
things we could never price before like
a minute of your time like as a jpeg
like a a byte on your heart or you know
a megabyte on your hard drive all that
type of stuff becomes priceable and just
to relate it i'm going to talk about the
d5 matrix come back up to the order book
come back up to
smart fiat then back up to subscription
inflation then back up to the rebundling
after the american anarchy okay so
what is the d5 matrix digital wallets
mean you can hold every asset in your
computer not just bitcoin not just
ethereum but fiat currencies like cbdc's
when central bank digital currencies
come out every stock every bond every
nft every video game potion you have a
billion items in your digital wallet
those billion items you just hold them
you trade them against the billion items
you have this gigantic table and every
existing exchange today a crypto
exchange a stock exchange a foreign
exchange you know foreign currency
exchange all of them can be considered
sub-matrices of these like a crypto
exchange's fiat currencies and
cryptocurrencies versus each other a
stock exchange of stocks and fiat
currencies of foreign exchanges
currencies versus currencies all those
are just submatrices of this massive d5
matrix and some of them are actually
exchanges and some of them are so-called
automated market makers where
like you've got some rare piece of art
and you've got uh you know or rather
like some some infrequently traded token
and you've got another infrequently
traded token this will give you some
conversion to them at some price it
might be a high price you can go
directly between them okay the d5 matrix
means everything is just getting
repriced all the time every asset
competes against every other asset uh
people don't understand how big a deal
this is it's kind of like it's a huge
deal huge huge deal yeah even for a
luddite like me it's a [ __ ] a huge deal
once you really start to look at it it's
huge enormous it is the internet of
wealth internet of money and it's going
to be similar it's like every newspaper
went online and then google news came
online and indexed them and suddenly
every newspaper is competing against
every other newspaper and so what that
meant was that
now all the ones that were just
reprinting ap stories were no longer
competitive and so lots of weak
newspapers that weren't adding that much
value died right
and uh so in the same way when every
asset is competing against every other
asset that is like extreme capitalism
okay there's no geographical advantage
anymore and not just competing but also
you can sort of cross-collateralize
and do all sorts of
wacky not wacky but new things that are
going to upend a lot of
our current thinking around how capital
flows that's right and one of the big
ones is it's actually a second attack on
on fiat currency the first attack is
that
bitcoin appreciates and bitcoin can't be
seized and so on like all the stuff
we've known in the last last 10 years
the second attack
you know what do they call it when you
sell a company or you go ipo they call
it a liquidity event right because cash
is
universal barter and you can exchange it
for other things whereas you can't
exchange stock directly the d5 matrix
changes that
everything is always liquid all the time
so at some price you can get a quote for
something so long as it's not like
banned by the state right and if you can
get a quote for something do you need to
actually convert it into cash you can
just do it instantaneously you can
liquidate it as necessary and in fact
you want to hold minimum necessary cash
and have everything else because cash
doesn't appreciate in fact cash
depreciates
okay
and so
now liquidity is itself a second whole
uh axis where it reduces the amount of
wealth held in fiat currencies the d5
matrix is this very very big thing it
will be to this decade what the social
graph was the previous one
you